course of non-fiction books
saturday through monday morning on book
tv
first son is bill minetaglio's biography
about republican presidential candidate
and texas governor george w bush
mr minitakio traces the history and
legacy of the bush family and the life
of george w bush from childhood to
governorship
during this discussion mr minitaglio
talks about meeting mr bush and why he
decided to write this book
it lasts a little under an hour
[Applause]
thanks thank you very much i
i was uh in dallas yesterday and i was
talking to some folks there about my 15
minutes of fame uh and and the book
writing process and i thought an apt
illustration was the the fact that in
last friday i was on the the today show
or had been invited to be on the today
show
uh which was an unusual event for me
and it got even stranger and more
unusual when i was there
because uh i got escorted into the
famous green room which uh isn't green
by the way and uh
uh it was told that i was gonna be
booked before the segment on the world's
largest giant squid
and so i you know so much for for
glamorous uh publishing
i met with george w in may and june of
last year on two different occasions
mainly to tell him that i was doing a
book about him and he's a very casual
guy i don't know if if many folks here
have had a chance to meet him he's a
very intense and casual guy
he
plopped his boots up on the desk he's
very almost
five
intimidating
dollar eel skin uh boots he plopped him
up on the desk and said billy boy you
know what what are you up to
it's one of his nicknames for me i'll
tell you about the other nickname that
he eventually developed for me over time
and i told him i i want to do a book
about you governor i think that you uh
are a pretty interesting guy this is a
pretty interesting state it's a very
merry uh fractious uh oftentimes over
the top uh kind of place to live i've
been here 21 years myself and i'm a and
like governor bush i'm a transplanted
north easterner i'm from new york he was
born in new haven connecticut
anyway i told him look texas is very
interesting i think you'd agree with me
on that level and also your last name
happens to be bush and you come from a
very potent
and powerful political dynasty and
really in my estimation i think your
family has
surpassed the kennedys as the most
powerful political dynasty in america in
this century
um and he said well let me think about
whether or not i want to you know help
you or cooperate with you really and
come back and see me in a couple of
weeks uh i came back to see him in a
couple of weeks
that was a more interesting and intense
meeting with governor bush i kind of saw
the full range of stripes
that i don't think a lot of us normally
see
as he's out campaigning and even you
know acting as governor i saw him a
little more up close and personal way he
was angry at me at our second meeting
because he had
begun to discern that i had begun the
kind of the wheels of
inquiry
into his life and
i think he felt a little uncomfortable
with that that
you know the process had begun almost
outside of his control in a way
um
and so we we had a very free wheeling
interesting discussion and again i saw
the full range of emotions from george w
a little a little bit angry which i i
learned later is uh
you know sometimes one of his character
traits he can get angry at you he can be
explosive a little bit of a mount
vesuvius frankly at times and it's
something that he's worked a lot at
tamping down in his life and trying to
control uh and then he was very cajoling
very funny
very irreverent some colorful language
was spoken
a real you know interesting intense
encounter and basically he said let me
think about really whether or not uh i
need to think some more whether we're
going to cooperate with you
and to talk to you and then he said you
know pull out your notebook
i'd already had out my notebook i had a
sneaking suspicion this might be the
last time i would i would see him so i
wanted to make sure that that every
moment that we had together i could
capture and i feverishly
taking notes anyway
he said let me give you some names of
people to talk to and he mentioned
a real variety of folks some of whom i'd
already known to talk to these were some
of his best friends people who had been
interviewed before
about his life and then he then he gave
me the name of his uh his little league
coach which i thought was kind of
interesting
he gave me the name of his personal
accountant which i thought was also
interesting it's kind of a
odd variety
and
yes i kind of took it as almost a green
light i think george w in some sense was
giving me a little bit of a green light
to look at his life while he still
contemplated whether or not he actually
was going to talk to me himself
i went home and a few weeks later i
began calling some of the folks that he
had mentioned including his little
league coach
and uh that that was a pretty
interesting conversation that the guy
out in uh it's an elderly gentleman out
in west texas
named frank itner and uh he told me that
george w was really the
you know one of the worst little league
players that he coached
and i i didn't read too much and i don't
know if that's symbolic or not but it's
uh
it it sort of became symbolic over time
for me
uh
what the little league coach told me was
he you know he was a a player he was
always in on every play
but he certainly wasn't the player that
his father was
and
when he told me that it you know it kind
of rested in the back of my mind and i
wrote it down i thought about it and it
kind of went away but as the the book
kind of progressed
and i began looking you know more at
george w's life it it actually seemed
very very symbolic uh to me of a lot of
things in george w's life
that
for him in almost every phase of his
life he's walked in his father's shadow
this enormous gigantic political legacy
and dynasty that exists
and again you know something a family
that i maintain has surpassed the
the kennedys in some ways i i didn't
really understand until i began this
process how closely
george w's life had emulated his
father's and how he had been affected by
this enormous incredibly enormous shadow
and
a lot of people are surprised when i use
the word shakespearean when i talk about
george w he might tell you that i'm
speaking as george w i'm the last guy to
read shakespeare or maybe even like
shakespeare
he might argue that and some of his
critics would certainly argue that but
as well
but
to me he's a guy that's really burdened
by an enormous legacy and a mantle of
expectations
uh and i kind of began to to
like that idea because i'm not an
acutely political writer by nature or
really by career
uh in the 21 years that i've been in
texas in writing i've worked in a
variety of newspapers i've written for a
number of national magazines and by and
large the stories that i've written or
the ones that i've liked to
write have been more about human nature
human interest and
almost really an interior look at people
if you will george w calls it
psychobabble by the way
and i kind of suggested to him when we
first met that that's where i was headed
i think that explained a little bit of
his caution
in meeting with me i wasn't a
traditional political writer and i think
he was a little bit worried about that
he uses this word against psychobabble
when he says it it rolls off his his
tongue like the worst curse imaginable
it's really an anathema it's a
psychobabble
and he gets very worked up and exercised
about it
he also says as his father says don't
lay me out on the couch
in other words don't psychoanalyze me
don't go there you know what you see is
what you get i'm a pretty exterior
person so don't don't go looking for
that deep interior and besides i'm not
going to ever tell you about it we keep
it very private we keep a stiff upper
lip
it almost a kind of a patrician
upper northeast kind of way
but i guess i was hell-bent on doing
that because i didn't know any better
and so i began kind of looking at at the
interior of george w and
some people have said
this probably will sound like a sales
job but some people have told me that
uh this book seems uh almost strangely
uh non-political
since it's about an acutely political
guy and that actually pleases me
to hear that and
you know perhaps even more flattering to
me of course is the thought that some
people have said it's almost novelistic
in a way and i've been criticized for
that frankly in some reviews that have
come out already
i've been
praised in some reviews uh but but also
criticized for taking that approach but
i thought that was the right way to go
it's not an edmond morris way i didn't
probably go that far to the point of
of inventing uh a persona or person to
walk alongside george w through his life
in in in times but i really tried to
take a
a different look at him through a
different kind of a prism and really the
only prism that i that i felt
comfortable with and that was through a
very
acutely human
and almost uh
you know psychological or psychobabble
way to use george w's word
um
i i learned uh one thing about george w
right off the bat as i began looking at
his life chronologically that uh at the
age of seven it's a little told story in
the bush household i think it it's
little told because they don't share a
lot of their inner
workings and their inner personal
stories or their inner tragedies i guess
you'd say
that at the age of seven when george w
was seven his younger
sister robin contracted leukemia
developed leukemia and died several
months later
i didn't know about that
and
what happened in that instance was that
george w
in my opinion was almost rendered and
only child
in the family and in a lot of ways was
smothered by barbara bush
and and he was then seven years older
than his brother jeb and i think that's
had a really lasting impact on and this
is getting into a deep psychobabble area
that i think george w would feel
uncomfortable with but i talked to a lot
of people in the family a lot of his
close relatives i spoke to his brother
jeb
who consented to a lengthy interview i
spoke to several of george w's uncles uh
president bush's brothers that is
several close cousins and they all kind
of backed up this theory that i
was looking at that
george w's whole life in in a way
was affected by that incident the fact
that he had to really draw close
to his mom
and it was almost smothered and then
beyond that was burdened with an even
greater level of expectations
he was you know truly the first son and
almost really an only child
it's so significant to me when you think
about george w and people have asked me
what's the most surprising thing i
learned what i learned was maybe the
most evident thing or i was surprised by
what was just sitting there right under
my nose
the guy is a dead ringer for his dad i
think increasingly so
when you walk into a room with the two
these days it's hard to tell the
difference sometimes but not only that
he went to the same high school as his
dad he went to the same college as his
dad
at college he belonged to the same
fraternity as his dad
he belonged to the same secret society
on campus this very closed door and an
almost mysterious
society at yale called skull and bones
he belonged to that group
as his dad head and as his grandfather
had then beyond that there are many many
other similarities he was engaged to be
married at one point in his life
at really the same juncture and in life
and career as his father had been
engaged uh he went into the same line of
work uh obviously first the oil game and
and when he did that he actually
replicated the the thing that his dad
had done many years earlier in 1948 the
elder george bush had jumped in a
studebaker
and drove down from the northeast
uh out to the wild and wooly outbacks of
midland and where he was accused of
being a carpetbagger by the way of
kind of coming down to
to take his place in the oil game
uh out in west texas george w did the
exact same thing in 1975 he jumped in a
cutlass not a studebaker drove cross
country from the the upper realms of the
northeast and went out to uh to midland
the same spot where his data tried to
get started and
that set off a whole nother path of
inquiry i began looking at all these
stations in life that george w had gone
to and had been in
and i began to measure
you know his success if you will at
those stations in life versus his
father's success
and and arguably
and i think this is borne out by a lot
of relatives in the family people who
talk to me george w simply didn't enjoy
the same level of success as his dad did
though they
were on similar paths
um
so that that
said a lot to me and i i really kind of
adhere to this almost shakespearean uh
view of george w i you know he he says
i'm not a guy that walks around with a
skull in my hand and you know i'm not
navel gazing and i'm not worried i'm
very free i'm very comfortable in my own
skin he says you know i
i don't remember any heaviness
you know really ruining my life i'm a
carefree lad these are these are all his
words
but i really think that he's not so
carefree i had so many people tell me
that in essence he really isn't that he
really is encumbered in some way
and may be challenged maybe that's a
nicer way to put it but he's motivated
in good part by this legacy this really
incredible powerful and really almost
quietly held legacy we know so much more
about the kennedys uh their tragedies
are played out uh you know unfortunately
you know sometimes very obviously
and maybe they've had greater spikes of
tragedy they definitely have had greater
spikes of tragedy in their life their
lives and in their family but there have
been
enormous challenging moments for george
w and again i think the real way to
understand him
is almost sometimes not in a political
way it's really to think about his role
in the family the way he's responded to
this uh almost crushing
to be somewhat dramatic but almost
crushing level of expectations that have
been placed on him
um
i talked to
to former lieutenant governor bob
bullock
uh
on his death bed uh earlier this year i
i was sitting around
my house and the phone rang and i i had
been pursuing
uh bullock for a while politely pursuing
him to ask him for an interview my phone
rang one afternoon
two three o'clock in the afternoon
and this really gravelly uh intimidating
voice you know popped out of the phone
you want to talk to me you better be
here in 15 minutes
and uh so you know i ran out the door
and uh i said okay that sounds like a
command more than an invitation uh but i
really wanted to interview him and uh
so i hopped in my car and
flew over to his house
kind of
lives very close to the state or had
lived close to the state capitol i went
inside and it was a very very powerful
moment and i think really in 20 years of
journalism i
had never had a more powerful interview
experience
he his wife opened the door she invited
me in
said that he
was feeling very ill
he had just returned from some form of
either radiation or chemotherapy
and uh was just laid up in bed and i
asked whether it was appropriate for me
to be there should i come back i don't
want to
you know be ghoulish frankly should i
come back and
she said no just pull up a chair you
know you could barely whisper so pull up
a chair stood very close to him
and uh for the next two hours you know i
just strapped myself in for what was a
very powerful and really emotional
experience he uh
i
again i almost felt like it was a
deathbed confession
to me and i learned a lot of very
interesting things about the way
politics works
or maybe doesn't work in texas or the
way the game is played and we talked a
lot but the point i'm getting to is that
that he uh
he kept lapsing in and out of
consciousness
and occasion occasionally would emerge
with a very incredibly uh
clear point and actually some other
almost psychedelic points if you will to
use a word he was deriding rosie
o'donnell at one point to me and really
vigorous and very colorful language
that's mentioned in my book uh
for seemingly no apparent reason it
seemed at the moment but
at one point he said to me
uh you know every son uh has to dream at
a necessity about their parents
uh he and then he began talking to me
actually in a very personal way about
his own son and some difficulties that
they had had in their own relationship
and and he told me further how he had
almost essentially adopted
george w bush as the son maybe that he
had never had
uh and then he further said uh to me
you know every son
even if they don't say it probably wants
to live up to their father's
expectations in some way
and uh
bullock uh you know again i kept trying
to excuse myself asking whether it was
okay for me to be there he said no no i
need for you to understand this
and he said uh can you only imagine if
your father was the president of the
united states you know none of us can
really understand that can you imagine
that can you imagine the burden of
expectations having to live up to that
uh and uh
at that point that was really
one of the last interviews that i did
for my book but i i felt it was a good
uh footnote i felt that i had actually
been on the right path
that was the right way to go
um it kind of confirmed my instincts
that that it was better to take a more
personal
look at george w than a political look
really and yeah and i'd suffer that the
consequences of that you know again a
lot of people have said
now that there have been a ton of
reviews the book's only been out a few
days but but in some of the reviews
people have faulted me again for not
taking an acutely political look at them
but
but i i
odd to say this about a you know a very
serious and somber moment with a man who
who would die several weeks later but i
felt better for what he had said to me i
felt that i had done the right thing in
some way and that this was the the right
way to
to
write this man's biography something
that i took very seriously
um
i'd be glad to answer any questions
or
duck any tomatoes or anything else uh uh
i won't sing any songs though i'm not
gonna do that go ahead
no i haven't this is my first yeah it
was my first i'll tell you what is it
asked if he has had done any other
biography
um
no i have not and uh i'll tell you what
i'm not gonna ever do again i'm never
gonna write a biography about a guy
running for office it i learned
a lot about uh frankly what i'd normally
do for a living you know i'm a daily
journalist and i learned
to maybe not like what i do
really in the profession at large uh
mainly because i saw things written
about me about what i was doing where i
was headed they were you know flatly
incorrect
so i
beyond that
you know this book started out almost
innocently i guess at when i started he
was you know quote just the governor of
texas and i really went into it with
that and that thought in mind i can
honestly tell you that i i didn't
know at that point this was uh you know
may of last year may of 1998 and he had
not yet announced officially that he was
running for
the presidency there's a lot of
speculation
um
but uh
in connection and in conjunction with my
editor was a very good editor in new
york we had decided that again uh
that would be you know that would be an
interesting development if that happened
and it it turned out that way it it
writing a book about a guy who's running
for the presidency really on the fly as
his campaign is developing as his people
are trying to position him and sculpt
his image
and then other people are on the hunt
for information about him uh and on the
hunt for all kinds of information
uh became a really daunting task because
i am i actually became a news story
people are scrambling for information
about george w bush and i became a news
story so it was kind of uncomfortable
for me probably a really good cautionary
tale i i learned a lot more about what i
do for a living and and you know maybe
why
some people have pretty strong feelings
about the media
yeah bill i'm a member of the media i'm
robert draper at gq hey how are you
doing it's good to meet you meet you um
two things uh one you mentioned uh
barbara bush and uh
your speculation that she had suffocated
george w i didn't see where you were
going with that in terms of how that
produced the man that we know oh yeah
yeah george w's got a line a really
famous line i know robert you you bet
with him and you've written some really
good stories about him to flatter you
here publicly but you have you have and
uh and in fact one of the definitive
stories about him i might add you really
have uh you know george w says i've got
my daddy's eyes and my momma's mouth and
it it always gets a laugh wherever he
delivers it it's a pretty good uh
campaign tool but i think he's he's
accurate he's right he's honest um
he's a dead ringer for his dad but he
has a needling uh
way about him as you know and
an irreverence about him a bluntness
about him forthrightness you might say
and
and maybe even a bit of combustible
nature about him that
that a lot of people in the family tell
me is really much more like barbara bush
and i think he got that in that period
when she began drawing him closer and
one of his uh his uncles told me that uh
in the 1950s
the elder george bush was really almost
an absentee father he was trying to make
millions in the oil game and he
eventually did as you know and he was in
the words of uh jonathan bush
the elder george bush was hard running
he was he was away from home a lot he
was down in houston he was back in the
northeast uh trying to raise the capital
to punch holes in the ground and
almost effortless leslie really raising
the capital in the northeast he was
going other family members and bringing
back some some investment money but uh
yeah even the little league coach kind
of kind of verified this he essentially
pointed out to me that barbara bush
might have been the world's first uh
soccer mom
in the sense that she was the little
league mom she was the one who showed up
at all the little league games
uh and not the elder bush so he became
more like his mom i think and and i
think that in some ways it makes him a
better politician
he's certainly less stiff-backed now
than his dad and he's more gregarious
and charismatic in some ways in a retail
politics kind of a way the grip and grin
kind of a way he moves easier in crowds
more like his mom than his his dad
the second question is as far afield
from his family uh have you gotten a
chance to take a look at the afterword
of hatfield's book and what do you make
of the allegations yeah i've i know what
you're referring to and for everybody
else here there's another book out uh
just recently in the last few days
called as a similar
name to mine it's called fortunate sun
and it's it's been getting uh uh some
level of interest and maybe even
excuse me lately i haven't read it
uh i haven't seen the afterward uh some
colleagues of mine as very capable
research assistants of mine have
read portions of the afterward to me uh
and that's really all that i know about
it i i i know it's embroiled right now i
mean literally as we speak in a little
bit of a contract he takes three sources
he does not uh
he doesn't name the sources yeah who
indicate that uh the bush in 1972 was
busted for cocaine and did community
service for it and that community
service was operation or project coal
yeah exactly yeah he's uh that's the
same story that i've heard that he um
this particular writer has suggested
that george w had to go into a form of
community service perhaps at a place in
houston called operation poll which was
a an inner city anti-poverty agency a
mentoring program that was in the third
ward of houston it no longer exists
um i
one thing that i'm i'm proud of on my
book and i pat myself on the back is the
level of sourcing in my book
i i was trying to count them up earlier
and i lost track i'm not a good counter
uh but there are
you know
500 600 footnotes in my book it's very
well sourced out and i can really credit
a guy sitting right behind you named
mike smith who's was my lead researcher
on the book an extraordinary
and very capable researcher for for
flogging me
as we wrapped up this book and uh you
know bill we need to resource triple
source
uh get every source down here possible
and i thought i had done a pretty good
job till mike pointed out that it wasn't
up to his standards so uh but i owe him
a great debt actually for for urging me
to do uh even more sourcing than i had
felt comfortable with i think he was
cognizant probably
in a more political way than i was the
stakes are very high you know right now
in this book
in in an odd way in a very specific way
is now almost a political entity in
itself
and i'm i'll tell you this i'm damn sure
glad that we sourced it as we did
especially in light of some of the
things that are cropping up uh as people
talk about other people's books and
whether
there are enough sources in it and are
they identified and so on i
i think named just about every source
that contributed to this book
i think it's very very clear where all
of the information in this book comes
from i'm not sure if i answered your
question only as far as i was curious
whether or not that had any ring of
truth to you and whether or not along
the way i'm sorry yeah and i do want to
answer that yeah i i interviewed uh
here's the way i'll do it i interviewed
i wanted to know a lot about project
pull um it's pretty interesting to me i
know the third ward really well i used
to live in houston and worked at the
houston chronicle one of my duties and
one of my duties over the years in texas
has been to write about poverty and the
inner city and social services that's
really my area of expertise
uh so i know the third ward it's it's a
you know a less affluent area on the
outskirts of houston and i'm sure some
of you here know know the area
so i wanted to know about this
organization why the heck george w bush
would be working there you know what
what's a guy from the other side of the
tracks the more affluent side of the
tracks doing there so i i exercised what
i thought was proper due diligence i
found one of the co-founders kind of
hard to find i found him um
deep in louisiana ernie land ernie ladd
exactly yeah and i asked him to former
professional football player named ernie
ladd i asked him
big cat
big ernie big cat lad
and i asked him why george w was there
and he you know flatly told me that he
was there because i was friends with his
father and his father you know wanted to
get him a job he thought it would be
good for him to be working in the inner
city
get exposed to uh
you know different things in life and
and it was good for him
you know he was a very blunt guy he said
it would be good for a white guy to come
to a black neighborhood
and and that
and
i also discovered in my research that
george w
two years before he went to work for
that organization was thinking about
running for state representative and
george w
likes to essentially suggest that i came
late to politics and that it kind of
occurred to me a little later in life
but you know really as early as 1971 he
was thinking about running for
significant office that state
representative district that he was
looking at happened to be pretty close
to her operation pull
was headquartered and it would be very
in keeping with
the bush
you know families political expediencies
and their way of studying things
and knowing when to make the right move
would be a good idea to go to work in an
organization like that build up your
civic resume
be seen in the neighborhood and and you
know maybe maybe position yourself to
run later i also interviewed the guy who
ran the program a guy named edgar arnold
who turned out to be one of george w s
good good pals during that juncture i
also interviewed another guy named david
anderson who was one of george w's
co-workers i interviewed david's
wife who also worked for a time at pole
so i i interviewed four people at this
little tiny inner city mentoring agency
and asked them point blank was george w
here
as a condition of punishment was he here
because he had done something bad
and was ordered to go here and i told
him i said i
you know probably
uh you know
i would think that
you know why would this guy be here he
doesn't have to be here and he really
didn't have to be there his parents were
were quite affluent at that time and
they all told me that
he was just simply there
um
really at the request of his father and
that that request had been my son needs
to be exposed uh to other things in life
it would be good for him
and of course i extrapolate a little
further it'd be good politically it
really would be good politically and
george w made reference to to working
there over time in in different
campaigns and at different different
junctures to you know tell people who
criticized him for for
the thought well gee you know how do you
know about life on the other side of the
tracks you were never there and and now
he is he's able to say well i was there
you know i was on the other side of the
tracks i worked there so uh
again i'm not sure if i
completely answered your question but
that's what i learned about that episode
i can tell you you probably want to buy
the papers over the next couple of days
they're going to be a lot of stories
i got a lot of phone calls today
just driving around
you did too very dramatic the new york
times uh the washington post a lot of
other people cbs evening news a lot of
people were calling me today uh and
again i honestly have not read the guy's
book uh it's here in the store i saw it
on the way in you might want to you know
pick up a copy i'll already did you
already did yeah i'm gonna get one and
uh
reported on by the by the the times in
the post well the there
as i understand it the times and the
post are both working on stories about
that book just just its existence
uh and they're working on stories about
the writer
and uh and even uh and again this is
extreme speculation at this point but my
understanding is just about the the fate
and future of the book itself
uh
you know what what will happen to that
book
so
go ahead uh
recently governor bush made a speech or
he made some remarks were critical of
the republican leadership and sure used
the phrase uh slouching to gamora which
i recognize as being from a book written
by uh robert burke who'd been a supreme
court nominee and i was just curious has
the governor read that book does he have
his advisors read it and maybe give him
like a condensed version of it it's a
very deep philosophical book and you
know i like the guy but he just doesn't
sure like me somebody who had read
something like that yeah i don't know i
don't know whether he's read that book i
can tell you almost as a
you know kind of a journalistic
technique
um i began trying to ask a question in
almost every single interview that i
that i did my editor had a great
suggestion to me at one point which i
initially didn't like he said
why don't you ask people what george w
bush's poetry is and i understood
immediately what he meant you know
what's in his core what's in his soul
what what really motivates him is there
a particular piece of music as i write
in my book is there an aria is there a
melody is there
a piece of dance a piece of choreography
that he saw that that stirred him is
there literally a poem uh is there a
book is there a it's something just
something that's you know all of us i
think
have something that stirs us it could be
another person
uh a sport you know maybe it's baseball
he loves baseball uh a lot and maybe he
sees a form of spirituality
this is this is where i go into the
psycho babel land i disappear into the
land of psychobabble that george w maybe
doesn't like so much but but i i i
thought that was pretty interesting and
it kind of fit in with you know what i
wanted to do so i began asking people
really as a
as an exercise in getting to that
question um
i thought the right way to do it or a
good way to do it one form of doing it
was to ask what books
george w likes to read
and um
i also asked a lot of my researchers i
had the real the benefit again of
working with with a crew of
extraordinary researchers again that to
flatter the best one mike smith who's
sitting in the back row uh he was really
my principal and lead researcher
but i had the benefit of working with
other people and i asked all of them
as they did some work for me try to find
out what george w reads
i became really almost obsessed by it
and i have to tell you that not many
people were able to answer that question
one day i was
over in the state capitol and i was
summoned into the office of george w's
press spokesperson karen hughes
and
she began lecturing me really in
about the number of books that george w
reads it was really almost a spontaneous
lecture
if you will is like being summoned into
the you know the principal's office uh
suddenly and
i understood it really to be a response
probably to the the fact that i had been
asking a lot of people in the family and
just elsewhere that same question and
she said to me you know george w reads
uh reads a lot of books you know and she
reads uh and of course you know which
ones and well he he's read the uh
biography of teddy roosevelt and winston
churchill and he likes mysteries
and so forth so i i i i'm being very
honest that was really the first i'd
heard that and i really did try to ask a
lot of people just point blank is there
a particular you know book perhaps that
that stirs him of course i i'm you know
being a little funny now i hope that you
know he's read my book and has some some
feelings about it i i think that he has
uh has read it but you know i don't know
in your writing group you find out uh
was he connected in any way with his
brother neal's uh involvement with the
savings and loan scandal in the 80s and
the big yeah you know yeah no i i you
know the bush family is extremely loyal
that's another amazing facet of their of
of the family george w saying uh
you have to be willing to throw yourself
on the grenade
you know for the family and really if
you know for my father it's an amazing
so to me it it says a lot it's almost a
combative and you know war-like
fealty to the family very very loyal so
he he you know he was with his brother
neil he
it's in the book george w at one point
said neil is getting hosed
that was the word that george w used
neil is getting hosed
um
primarily because he's the president's
son and he's the victim of you know a
media backwash and just this resistance
the media and other people attacking
our father our father
in terms of a real technical
relationship in that that regard it was
a you know pretty
widespread
collapse of a of a savings and loan in
colorado i didn't see any direct
connection there's a really good book
simply called silverado
that was written by somebody i think at
one of the denver newspapers that really
really uh examines that whole uh
uh event in you know great detail it's a
real good book
couple things uh ultimately he didn't
cooperate right did you hear that who
did you hear that from karen hughes or
yeah well lieutenant yeah yeah exactly i
called religiously i really did in fact
i kept a log for a while the number of
phone calls i would place over there and
i really honestly wanted to
you know it's the right thing to do it's
just what i do for a living you you
you continue to ask for an interview and
then when you begin interviewing other
people you go back to the original uh
sort of subject and ask them to you know
respond to what other people have said
so it's kind of due diligence i guess
i lost track again i could probably say
it was hundreds of inquiries via fax
a letter i wrote personal letters i
made numerous numerous phone calls and
you know in my acknowledgments i
actually thank the the recipient of all
my phone calls a long-suffering member
of a staff who had to endure you know my
my voice
pleading cajoling whining you know i
tried all kinds of different
approaches really just sort of how i was
how i was doing that day but no we we
never met again i uh
what's interesting to me i was never
officially told that we would never meet
again i i did you know establish i did
get some form of an answer and the
answer was that he he's still weighing
whether to to meet with you again
whether whether to grant another meeting
and
almost as an exercise in uh
oh i don't know kind of for for my own
uh self-interest on the
the the week that i was going to that i
had to finish up the book and i was
contractually committed to delivering
the book to my publisher i decided yet
again that i would try you know one more
time the book was done it was
pretty much done in a little box we were
feverishly running around fact checking
and sourcing again but that week i
decided i would try again
and uh i was told that week that he was
still
he still really hadn't made up his mind
so he i you know i envisioned myself you
know flying down to the fedex at eight
o'clock at night which is how my book
got delivered to new york in real
dramatic fashion maybe stereotypical
fashion
that i would be you know scrawling
something in and pencil in the margins
you know right there in fedex
filling out the fedex farm with one hand
and and writing you know the ending to
my book or including some thoughts from
him with the other since i just talked
to him on a cell phone but it didn't
work out that way so
i wanted to talk a little bit about the
hardball gig
what was that like you're you're
referring to my appearing on the
hardball show with chris matthews yeah
i'm interrupted by him a lot was that a
like uh yeah i mean you feel like you've
arrived now
well yeah i i think i was delivered
somewhere i don't know if i arrived
anywhere i think i was launched to outer
space you know i talked to my wife uh
you know she i think is
she's been watching me uh i i've kind of
refused to watch i sound like you know a
movie yeah i don't want to watch
my performance you know but i i
i actually uh my wife told me she said i
don't know who you are you know in
essence i'm paraphrasing but it's not
the guy that i
married or lived with you look like you
drank you know 800 cups of coffee
i became too much coffee man at that
point i was i and it was really because
i was just hanging on to his
his jet ski you know my foot was caught
in the little the tow line
and i just began talking really i have
no idea what i said
actually i did it was funny i
i
went back to my hotel room i had
15 interviews in in one day and that was
one of them that was the the and they
were most of them were televised or or
taped for television
uh and or radio so they were they were
very uh it was kind of an intense a long
day
and uh i i was went back to my hotel and
was really almost almost passing out and
i flipped on the tv to just sort of calm
down and you know maybe watch
the end of the ball game or something
and
whatever and there i was of course it
was great you know it makes for a good
story now but there i was on hardball
they were replaying the episode and even
i couldn't understand what i was saying
i had no
earthly idea what i said i just strapped
myself in and
it was fun he's actually a really nice
guy we talked afterwards i'll tell you
something really funny i think it's
funny anyway i uh
i think people do this here in the store
too it wouldn't surprise me if they do
in this was in washington in a bookstore
i went in because i had a spare 10
minutes and i went in to to look at my
book
on the shelf
and so i just thought that would be a
fun thing to do and maybe you know if it
wasn't displayed just you know i'll move
it
over there over in front of the edmond
morris book you know
so um
uh
i'm doing this or thinking of doing it
and
i look over my shoulder and chris
matthews has just walked in the store
and i i something told me
just step over here around the corner a
little bit let's take a look
and uh chris went right up to the
counter and you know essentially said
you know where's my book because he had
written a book and he was really there
for the to do the same thing that i had
just done
so i felt pretty good about that that he
was there to check on his his book and
maybe you know
sell an extra copy just by being there
so he's a very nice guy that was an
incredibly intense experience yeah very
intense i uh
only probably
outpaced by having to appear
on a show with oliver north and paul
begala they have their own also
political affairs show and
that was
also intense and in many ways more
intense so
yeah thanks
mike my estimable researcher mike smith
i'm just wondering um
which
did uh governor bush give you any kind
of special nickname
and i was also wondering what uh karl
rove's nickname was
these these are leading questions being
asked but but they're good questions and
i'm glad you asked them
and we'll speak later uh about your
health benefits in fact there won't be
any uh
the uh
yeah yeah actually over time you know
governor bush one of his hallmarks and
actually one of the things that people
maybe suggest that he does too much of
is grant people nicknames he loved nick
he loves nicknames
robert you might have one i don't know
he might have endowed you with one
you know he started off by calling me
billy boy
um
and and uh over time i began noticing
that he's got a lot of nicknames for
people and you know he calls his friends
a spider
or weedy
and uh
rhodan
uh big chief a lot of you know names a
lot of them have interesting
you know derivations and reasons for
being uh i
i was told
by a very close advisor of his one of my
really good sources in the book and a
guy that i mentioned a lot and attribute
a lot of things too he said you know
what they're calling you these days
uh they're calling you mononucleosis
and uh i
said that could be read you know again
many different ways i i tried to i never
had mono but i knew people who had it
and it was almost you know it's kind of
a comical you know it's obviously an
illness but it you know people
sometimes laugh about it you know
contracted by from kissing
uh so what did that mean you know what
what was the symbolism of that uh it
also makes you sleepy and i might be
wrong on this so you know see is that a
forecast is that a pre-review of my book
this is going to be a sleepy book by a
sleepy guy
is he a kiss-up is he a kiss off
um i i didn't know exactly what it meant
and i even thought perhaps it was a
corruption of my last name which is very
hard mini taglio maybe it as you a lot
of people when they say my name they
start off strong and then begin to fade
and they get minute and then it i
thought maybe
mononucleosis maybe finished
my name within a different way than it
normally ends
mike also asked about a nickname that
that
is applied to his principal
political consolieri his his main
political advisor a man named karl rove
who some people in the room might might
know a very powerful political figure i
i maintain he's the lee atwater of texas
and and uh the guy in some ways that's
credited with being the maybe the person
who's directed george w to a lot of
books and has advised him on things to
to read and look at
but his nickname
i was told and i was told this by a
pretty high-ranking
official in texas is also quoted in the
book that his nickname is turd blossom
and that uh it uh has a lot to do uh oh
yeah
that made me curious
what did you do to deserve that is that
is that good or bad that's beyond
mononucleosis in some ways and and uh
what i heard was that it has to do with
the fact that wherever this guy goes uh
stuff
stuff
is sure to pop up stuff is about to
happen maybe some stuff will hit the fan
just things happen and uh so that that
that's yeah that's probably one of the
more colorful nicknames inside the bush
camp as as i learned it
thanks a lot
okay something else real quick
in these states back east so they
realized how little power the governor
has he's mainly a symbolic ceremonial
person here in texas no that's a that's
a good question i spent a lot of time in
washington and actually just talking to
a lot of the you know the real talking
head guys up there whom you think would
maybe know some of that or had checked
into a little bit considering where
george w is right now they were kind of
surprised frankly that i when when i
explored that with him a little bit yeah
you know constitutionally
the governor's office here is not an
enormously strong
position compared to maybe some other
states and it's been described to me
even by uh
the speaker of the house and and former
lieutenant governor bullock as a as a
place that calls for a cheerleading a
lot of salesmanship um
uh kind of a sense of cajoling and
getting people to work together and
building a consensus and things like
that uh you know
and i maintain in my book i flatly state
it though those are skills that george w
seems absolutely suited for he he
literally was a cheerleader in his life
he doesn't like to talk a lot about that
it's as he says it doesn't being a male
cheerleader
sometimes doesn't uh sell too well in
texas it doesn't go over too well maybe
in some quarters of texas and he was the
head uh cheerleader at the all-male
private school that he went to phillips
andover academy in in massachusetts um
and he he was a salesman in the in the
oil game when he first started out that
was really his job it was to kind of
sell people on deals
get them to invest in this particular
piece of land and also to to get uh
ranchers out there to to you know
essentially sell him some land too so
he's kind of a middle man broker and
those are skills that that are good to
have actually in texas but but yeah
you're exactly right i don't think a lot
of people know that that's the way
that's one of the political verities of
life in texas yeah
thanks a lot oh i'm sorry go ahead yeah
go ahead sure uh elizabeth dole made the
announcement was it yesterday that uh
she was withdrawn
um i read that as having quite a bit of
bitterness at the amount of money
um i i just curious oh yeah i don't know
that i mean she might yeah i don't know
whether she is bitter or not i can't
answer that but you know obviously he's
got a lot of money and i i do know that
some of the candidates have expressed
that uh you know he's got more money
than the you know 60 million plus in his
warchest more than you know maybe some
of the gross national products of some
small countries so yeah there's there's
some sense that they're being you know
washed over by an enormous
tide and financial tide and that's
really the underlying reason why she
dropped out there's just too much money
that she's
stacked up against
yeah go ahead
uh i have a question about that actually
i saw an interview today with with
elizabeth dole i think it was on abc or
something and she suggested that um
bush started raising the money in 96.
do you think already then he he knew
that he was going to run for president
that's a great question yeah i i
you know he he'll say no of course and
even when i was meeting with him he was
saying uh you know he was he was kind of
arguing with me this was in uh 1998 in
may and june he was saying i know the
real reason you're here is you're you're
convinced that i'm going to run for the
presidency and you know and i i said uh
you know that could happen certainly
that's a strong possibility and and of
course it would make your story more
interesting but i i don't know and i i
think the wheels were turning and and
some people you know there's uh yet
again to do free promotion for another
book which i'm not supposed to do
there's going to be another book
there'll be several more books coming
out including a very good one by molly
ivins in fact that we'll talk a lot
about it the things that i have not
talked about in my book mainly george
w's policies
you know molly is molly if you know
molly she's coming at it from a
particular mali viewpoint and and her
book is going to be entitled shrub
so i think you have a real feeling you
know for where she's going uh but it
will be a good you know exhaustive and
very colorful examination of her
uh her views on his policies what i'm
getting at is that there's another book
in the works that i've heard about that
might come out early next year
that speculates that george w's i've
heard this and so i'm speculating here
but i've heard that this author will
explore
the thought that george w's
real motivation for running for the
presidency was to avenge
his father's defeat
that he's all about loyalty to the
degree that he's trying to exact some
measure of revenge for his dad you know
being voted out of office and george w
credits uh well blames you know the
media uh often and primarily
for uh you know quote buying into
bill clinton at the expense of his
father so uh i think he set the wheels
and motions a long time ago i don't know
the precise date but i think it predates
his official announcement for sure he's
been thinking about it for a long
there's a lot of time
within the family like with jeb for
instance with this whole
with the campaign and and coordination
coordination in a sense one is
sacrificing the other and they decided
in advance well
it's his turn and i'm i'm gonna wait
yeah yeah it's funny i almost thought
you said ordination in the sense of uh
you know there being this very uh
planned uh in in almost a hierarchy and
which would actually almost be an
appropriate question yeah there's
incredible coordination the the
campaigns when they were both running
for um for governor in both instances as
you know jeb running for governor in
florida they're exchanging uh campaign
information they're exchanging tapes
and uh you know some of my colleagues
who know a lot more about this than me
who really studied perhaps those
campaigns
you you would hear them say a lot of the
same things i mean really almost uh
echoing the exact same campaign slogans
and and promises and so on enormous
coordination they meet every august up
in kennebunkport and uh they have what
some members of the family call
political uh conclaves they gather and
they they plot strategy it's not just a
time to gather and you know be with the
family and go fishing and play golf a
lot of the the public things that we see
they go up there and they plot
strategy you know politics uh is what
the bushes do
and people in the family have told me
it's in their blood it's in their genes
uh and in a lot of ways they were born
as i say really in page one in my book
page two
that they were
you know their george w as an example
was born into politics in almost every
way
imaginable it's under his skin
go ahead i have a question uh before he
was running for president before it came
out
is the bush family much in the press
like up in the east in boston or
whatever
meaning are they being were they just
you know in the general number like the
kennedys you know are kind of embracing
yeah no no they're they're not and that
was the real surprise to me and actually
a happy moment for me because i gave you
something to write about but no the you
know there are two sides of the family
the bushes and the walkers
and i was just knocked out by the fact
that the walkers have just enormous
incredible roots in uh at all high
levels of politics and commerce in this
country you know going back to the mid
19th century and not much of that has
been written they they were uh
you know founders of the most important
brokerage firms in the united states
they have helped to build some really
monumental i think monumental uh
structures and edifices places
institutions madison square garden uh
the belmont racetrack where you know
part of the triple crown is run
brown brothers harriman again one of the
truly powerful uh
brokerage brokerages in the united
states the bushes and walkers uh are
intimately tied in there but but you
really wouldn't know it from reading you
know the papers up there i see that the
nice man jeremy from book people is
giving me the high side so uh
i just don't want to run out of time and
make sure everybody can get there sure
yeah i'd be glad to sign any books if
it won't diminish the value
[Applause]
has written for a number of texas
publications including the san antonio
express news the houston chronicle and
the dallas morning news
times books publishes this book first
son